foreign
flickers of fear so the movie we're
talking about today the Boogeyman from
1980.
now this
I feel like this was one of those movies
that I used to see the cover of like in
the video store all the time like back
in the day but I never actually got
around to renting it probably because I
thought it was just like maybe another
forgettable slasher like Halloween
ripoff or something like that
and I'm gonna say like as far as that
goes it sort of is but it also has kind
of an interesting Supernatural angle to
it that actually kind of distinguishes
it somewhat from kind of your standard
like Teenage you know
summer camp pack and slash type of uh
type of thing now don't get me wrong I'm
not saying that this is all that good of
a movie by any means but it does have
like a couple of creative ideas in there
kind of amid all the other you know kind
of derivative stuff and I'm gonna say I
definitely feel like it has enough of a
cult following that it's pretty fair to
say that there is like a contingent of
horror fandom that would probably
consider it something like a Hidden Gem
or something like that so take of that
which you will so this movie was
actually directed by and I'm sorry if
I'm pronouncing his name wrong but um
Yuli lamo I think is how you pronounce
it he was a German actor director
um he actually very frequently
collaborated with um RW fastbinder so
you know uh also hung out with Andy
Warhol and that whole Factory gang
um after he actually directed The Very
iconic like documentary blank generation
which was kind of the movie focused
generally on the New York City punk rock
scene back in the day specific quickly
on Richard hell and the voidoids but
after he did that which I think came out
in also in 1980 like before this one he
decided he was going to try to direct a
horror film uh since of course in 1980
the you know low budget horror was very
much a thing they were really kind of
making a splash because you know
Halloween had come out two years before
and everyone was trying to cash in on it
you know and I will say that one
criticism that kind of gets hurled at
the boogeyman a lot is how much it if
you want to call it homages Halloween
particularly in the opening scenes
though I feel like as it goes on it
becomes less and less like Halloween but
there are definitely like a few scenes
in here that are
pretty straight you know pretty
obviously like influenced by that
um movie also has a couple small nods to
The Exorcist and a pretty clear nod to
the Amityville Horror but I feel like it
doesn't so much rip off those movies as
kind of like use bits and pieces from
them to kind of build its own sort of
quirky narrative you know what I mean I
mean and I guess something about the
movie like particularly resonated with
audiences because it was like a modest
hit and actually ended up spawning two
sequels now both of those sequels I
haven't seen either one of them but from
what I've read both of them leaned very
very heavily on flashbacks so it could
use as much of the first movie as
possible so I think so I don't know if
it's as much as like a quarter or a half
of the footage of like the second and
third movies like used flashbacks and
like just used footage from the first
movie but I've heard that it was a lot
of that but there was actually a series
uh expand on the lore which started in
2018 and might still be going I'm not
entirely sure about that though so at
the beginning of the movie which is set
either like in the late 50s or early 60s
might be like right around 1960. we see
like a young brother and sister and
they're out on their porch of their
house at night and they're kind of
looking in the window at their mom and
her sort of like brute of a boyfriend
and they're kind of getting ready to get
busy on the couch right
now mom takes off one of her stockings
and puts it over the guy's head like as
a little flirtatious joke or whatever so
it kind of I kind of thought when I was
watching it and I kind of said this out
loud I was like he looks like he looks
like he's about to go into a convenience
store and I'll be taking these Huggies
and whatever cash you got you know what
I mean so bonus points if you know what
movie that's from but yeah so he looks
kind of like that so she put the thing
over his head like making him look like
he's about to rob a liquor store and uh
so then so they're doing that and then
the guy kind of glances to the side and
sees the two kids like looking in at
them now he gets mad and he goes out
there and drags the kids like what are
you watching us for and all this other
kind of crap so with the mom's approval
he actually drags the kids upstairs
um takes the little boy his name is
Willie ties him to the bed in his
bedroom and like puts a gag in his mouth
and it's just gonna like leave him there
all night I guess and then Mom like
basically tells the little girl whose
name is Lacey she's like a little bit
younger to get her ass off to bed and
this like doesn't involve her you know
what I mean so Lacey who I think is
about three or four ish
um she doesn't go to bed though she
actually goes into the kitchen grabs a
big ass knife that's been left out and
uses it to cut her brother free like Cut
the Ropes
um her brother then takes the knife down
the hall in like a POV shot that looks
very reminiscent of that sequence from
Halloween where you know Michael Myers
is a little kid is like going down the
you know it's from his point of view as
he goes down and stabs his sister so you
can tell that this is obagging that so
Willie goes down the hall with this
knife and just stabs the absolute [__]
out of the mom's boyfriend
like while he's in bed and Lacey watches
the whole thing in this big mirror which
is on the wall in the mom's bedroom like
across from the across from the bed
so the movie then jumps ahead 20 years
and Willie and Lacey are now grown up
obviously uh Lacey is actually played by
Susanna love who not only co-wrote the
screenplay but was actually married to
the directory lulamel at the time
um so Lacey kind of seems on the surface
to kind of have gotten her [__] together
she's married to this local cop and they
have like a seemingly well-adjusted
little son whose name is Kevin
Willie though
um he's clearly still suffering some
trauma he's been completely mute since
the whole murder incident uh 20 years
prior so they both live and work on this
big huge Farm which is owned by their
aunt and uncle and the implication is I
don't think they say this outright but
the implication is that they were sent
there as kids like after the murder
incident and have just lived there ever
since uh Willie by the way is played by
Nicholas love who is Susanna's brother
in real life so it seems that
um maybe some kind of like uneasy piece
has been arrived at like in regards to
that whole murder event that happened
like a long time ago but one day uh this
letter arrives from Lacey and Willie's
mom
and she tells them that she's dying and
she wants to see them one last time
so this letter seems to dredge up all of
those bad memories again and Lacey
starts having nightmares
um also both Lacey and Willie start
freaking out whenever they're whenever
they see mirrors you know what I mean
the weird thing though with the plot
point with this letter from their mom is
that even though Lacey and her husband
Jake they actually discuss maybe it
would be good if you went to see your
mom because they haven't seen her since
that night
um but they never actually do and I kind
of feel like that whole thread is sort
of like eventually completely forgotten
about and like never mentioned again
which I thought was kind of strange so
anyway uh because Lacey is starting to
act a little bit Looney Tunes uh
claiming to see quote unquote him every
time she looks in a mirror Jake actually
takes her to a psychiatrist who is
played by John Carradine by the way uh
the psychiatrist tells her that she
definitely should go see her mom and
while she's at it she should probably go
back to the childhood home where the
stabbing occurred so that she'll have
memories of it the way it looks now
instead of the way it looked 20 years
ago like in Social stop dwelling on it
so that actually does seem like a pretty
solid idea so you know fair play to Dr
Carradine there so Jake actually does
take Lacey to the house
another house happens to be up for sale
the only people at home when they go up
there are two are like two teenage girls
and they're like pre-teen or tween
brother who are like the children of the
owners who are away
so these kids they know their house is
for sale and they know that people come
by to look at it so they let you know
Lacey and Jake inside to come and have a
poke around because it's like oh yeah
we're totally gonna buy this house they
don't tell them that Lacey used to live
there now everything seems to be going
fine and Lacey is just like oh yeah this
is kind of the same but this is they've
changed this and that and the other
thing is she seems like she's having an
okay time with it but then
Lacey goes into the room that used to be
her mom's bedroom and notes to her
absolute horror that the mirror that she
saw the murder in is still there
now she actually sees in the same mirror
she sees the boyfriend with the stocking
on his head like laying in the bed like
she doesn't see it in the actual room
but she just like sees it in the mirror
and he gets up and like seems like he's
starting to like come toward her and
stuff like that and at that point she
just screams her [__] head off picks
up a chair and just like [__] smashes
the [__] out of the mirror and just like
breaks it all over the place so her
husband Jake as well as the kids that
live in the house they run up there and
be like um hey lady are you okay you
know what I mean uh but Jake is like
pretty tired of all these hysterics at
this point so he decides that he's gonna
take he picks up all the almost all the
broken pieces of the mirror and he's
like we're gonna take this mirror back
to the house I'm gonna put it back
together and you'll be able to see that
it's just like a regular ass mirror you
know what I mean
um so he like puts all the pieces in a
paper bag and stuff but he misses one of
them which is kind of something that
will end up biting people in the ass
later on
so after Jake and Lacey leave the
teenagers and their brother they kind of
like mentioned a little bit of lore
you know in regards to this movie by
mentioning how their grandma always said
that whenever a mirror broke anything
that it saw would be like released so
you're just kind of like uh oh you know
what I mean so it's that kind of
situation and although this actually
isn't mentioned out right in the film
but you know the whole thing about
um putting the uh putting the pieces of
the mirror like the broken mirror in a
paper bag that is actually I think it's
like a fairly common folklore thing like
I had heard it before like if you break
a mirror you're supposed to like put all
the pieces in a paper bag specifically
and then bury the paper bag and that's
supposed to keep you from getting the
bad luck you know what I mean like I
said I don't obviously believe that but
I think that's like a pretty common uh
folklore thing so I thought it was
interesting that they put it in the
movie without really drawing a lot of
attention to it you know so back at The
Farmhouse Jake very meticulously like
puts the mirror back together which is
that's some commitment I'm gonna say and
he hangs it on the kitchen wall at The
Farmhouse hoping again that Lacey will
realize look it's just a mirror like
there's nothing Supernatural about it or
anything like that however like both
Lacey and her brother are pretty dubious
about it because they've both like seen
the ghost like in the mirror and Willie
matter of fact has actually started
painting over all the other mirrors in
The Farmhouse like with black paint you
know what I mean but Lacey decides well
she's maybe gonna play along with this
whole thing because she doesn't really
want her husband to think that she's
just completely flipped out right
now meanwhile because A Shard of the
mirror was left behind in the house like
with the teenagers and the boy like the
childhood home all three of them of
those people are horribly horribly
killed
either in a way that makes it look like
the mirror is like possessing them to do
things to themselves or by other kind of
like Paranormal means right like um for
example like the one girl actually stabs
herself in the throat with scissors like
almost like why am I doing this oh my
God you know what I mean it's that kind
of thing
um the other girl gets killed when the
door of the medicine cabinet like bashes
her in the head and I was just kind of
like pretty sure the door of a medicine
cabinet isn't gonna like kill you I
don't even think it would really knock
you out it's not heavy enough but it's
like it must be one of those [__]
titanium like medicine cabinets that
I've heard so much about I don't really
know I thought they were gonna like
Circle back and be like Oh and then this
other thing happened like it dropped
like a [__] thing on her head or
something like that but it didn't like
apparently [__] that just killed her
also like the little boy he's actually
killed when he's like sticks his head
through a window and like the window
frame like falls down and like breaks
his neck or whatever so like all three
of them are killed and you're led to
assume it's because this Spirit or
whatever
came out of this like one little piece
of the mirror that was left you know so
after that like a bunch of sort of
related events happen
Willy ends up nearly strangling a
neighbor lady who comes over to the farm
to get eggs and like starts straight up
flirting with him though it's not really
explained why he does it but I guess
you're led to assume that he's possessed
or something like that Lacey's son Kevin
he actually gets A Shard from the mirror
like stuck on the bottom of his shoe
like without knowing about it and then
he him and Lacey go on a fishing trip
and that indirectly causes two
completely random people who are like
across the lake from them to get killed
by the mirror ghost because it keeps
like reflecting and I guess that's the
sphere of influence is like wherever the
mirror reflects or whatever
um so the two people they actually this
is actually kind of an interesting scene
but one of the guys he goes back to the
car to get something and gets like
skewered through the mouth with like a
ice pick or something like that and then
like this other girl comes to see what
the [__] has taken him so long and like
the the car door like pushes her butt in
and she like gets skewered on the same
you know thing that's sticking out of
his mouth so it looks like they're just
like in there kissing but they're
actually scared to death which I thought
was kind of cool it's not super graphic
but I thought it was like a cute idea
um there's also a scene where Willie
almost gets run through by like a
pitchfork that's kind of flying around
by itself
um but he gets saved at the last minute
by Lacey like she sees it kind of coming
and she like pulls him out of the way
you know so after some more crazy [__]
like that happens it seems like the
whole family like the ant knuckle and
everybody is now on board with the idea
that the mom's dead boyfriend who Willie
killed like when he was little like 20
years ago has indeed escaped from the
mirror and is like essentially going on
a rampage
so they decide they're gonna call a
priest for help but what happens after
that like the priest is in there doing
the exorcism and all that which is where
like the similarities to The Exorcist
come through however a piece of the
mirror in the kitchen like kind of like
goes like that it like comes out of the
mirror and it puts itself over Lacey's
eye which is like a little bit cheesy
but also kind of cool you know what I
mean it's kind of just straddling that
line a little bit
so it goes on her eye everything goes
like the light goes green and everything
like that and then the ghost is actually
like I guess it's possessing her you
know like the mirror is like
giving you like like I said a sphere of
influence so like the ghost wherever
pieces of the mirror are like the ghosts
can influence the environment like
paranormally I guess is what they're
saying
so
most people most of the people
characters get killed uh the aunt and
uncle get killed the priest gets killed
Jake almost gets killed but he actually
survives Willy also overcomes his
muteness just at the height of the
festivities like all he says so like he
basically like yells his sister's name
and then he can talk like after that
that's usually what they do if there's a
mute character you know that they're
gonna during some big like trauma during
the climax they're gonna be like ah and
then they're gonna be like oh my God I
can talk now you know what I mean they
always do that in movies but yeah so
they did it here too
so finally after all this big like final
confrontation
um you know where Lacey actually finally
gets free of The Ghost and all this
other [__] so finally Jake and Willie
and Lacey and everybody that survived
they take the mirror off the wall
and toss it in this deep well like out
front like on the farm and this big huge
Fireball like erupts from the well which
okay I guess it was like a demonic seita
whatever it was I don't know and this um
while they're doing that the house in
the background has those Amityville
Windows you know what I'm talking about
like the little
kind of semi-circular
windows and there's like red light
coming through there so I was like oh
that's very Amityville Horror but you
can tell they were deliberately homaging
that so that's what so the red lights
going in the background like while this
[__] mirror blows up in the well or
whatever
now so after that so that's kind of like
the end but then there's like a little
kind of Coda where they're at the
cemetery like putting flowers on the
grave of their aunt and uncle who like I
said got killed during this whole brew
HaHa
and I guess they were setting up the
sequel
um because one Shard of the mirror which
I guess was still stuck to this kid's
shoe because holy crap this was the most
like persistent mirror Shard hit all the
land like stuck on the bottom of this
little shoe like that and nobody noticed
it so if one Shard of the mirror remains
that means that the ghost can still like
pop out of it and like [__] [__] up so I
guess like I said that's what they were
setting it up oh there's this one piece
so left you know what I mean because he
could he could affect the environment
the ghost could even if it was just like
little
like dust you know what I mean like
little dust glad like you know pieces of
glass so any any piece of that mirror uh
would wherever it was would allow him to
like do [__] wherever it was you know
what I mean so as I mentioned I'm gonna
say this isn't all that great of a movie
like from an objective standpoint
um the acting depend is generally kind
of subpar some people better than others
uh the editing kind of wonky uh I didn't
really get what they were going for with
it the pacing is
kind of slow in places even though the
movie's not long I think it's only 92
minutes something like that
um and I'm gonna say that like the exact
mechanics and like the rules of the
Cursed Mirror aren't really laid out all
that concisely
um and it kind of like contradicts
itself at times like I said generally it
seems like wherever there's pieces of
the mirror then the ghost can [__] [__]
up but sometimes and sometimes not you
know what I mean and as I mentioned
earlier too some plot threads like such
as oh we're gonna go visit the mom like
the letter they got from Mom and oh
she's dying and maybe we should go see
her it's like that they were introduced
but then it doesn't go anywhere like
they never mention it again they never
mentioned the letter they never
mentioned going to see her anything like
that so I thought that was a little odd
because I thought that was going to be
like more of a thing and I'm gonna say
too that like a couple of incidents like
uh most most notably I think like
Willy's attack on the neighbor lady
where he like tries to strangle her
um they don't really explain why he did
that like I said I'm led to assume that
it was because he was possessed but so
they were showing that the ghost could
possess people if he wanted to but they
didn't really I don't know they didn't
really explain that all that
sufficiently in my opinion
um and I'm gonna say too like the kills
and the gore there's really nothing
special about them
um this movie actually did you wouldn't
believe it well maybe you would but this
movie actually did turn up on you know
the UK case video nasties list but it's
really really tame I mean really the the
most graphic kill is the girl stabbing
herself with the scissors which is
actually like pretty well done and
everything but other than that like a
lot of the people either just kind of
die off screen or it's just kind of like
oh there's some blood on their face and
that's about it so it's not like gory or
anything and I'm also going to say too
that because I know a lot of people that
are into 80s horror like you you know
you like you some gratuitous new nudity
because they did put a lot of that in
there but if you're looking out for that
you're probably also going to be
disappointed with this movie because
there's really only one as far as I can
remember like one partial titty shot
like the same girl that stabs herself
with the scissors like her uh shirt
comes open and like you can kind of see
like half of a tit or something like
that but that's pretty I think that's it
I don't think there's any more nudity in
it
um but all that said uh this was still
like worth watching I thought I mean
yeah it cobbles together bits from lots
of other movies but the movie actually
does have its own kind of original angle
with the supernatural thing and that
actually does go a long way in my book
it was trying to do something different
um I'm going to say too that I love the
score which is not something that I
would usually notice but I really like
the score of this one it's by a guy
named Tim krogg
um and actually it's so good that I
might actually just like listen to it
all on its own like without the movie
but yeah I really did like the score a
lot so that's another point in its favor
so you know if you're in the mood for
kind of like an 80s slasher with a
supernatural kind of twist to it
um you know then there's a lot worse
movies out there than this and like I
said a lot of people do seem to like
this one enough that they made a couple
sequels to it so it's on a shutter at
least as of this recording which is
August of 2023 so if you haven't seen it
like check it out and let me know what
you think about in the comments that'll
do it for this flickers of fear and I'll
see you guys again on the next one bye